Baker is resting because he has some
pain in his arm so he's okay but they
don't want to further complicate his
medical condition so we will be seeing
the challengers mid player Poe play in
his stead clean two very one-sided games
and I got to say Belz this one was not
about poy no and fate here he is going
to take Zas out just as a Parting Gift
goodbye so hold on hold on so T1 just
got two zeroed I think we really do see
how important Faker is to T1 and man I I
I have no words B moving on down Hook is
going to connect there onto cuz is now
carrier taking so much damage he will be
taken out Poe as well is going to
explode and somehow it's another kill
for the bin as well as owner is running
away PD finds the flash incinerate look
at how fast he's going it's a double
kill what aiming on four kills on Bane
at 6 minutes Mak get a triple oh
goodness me it could not have gone worse
for T1 so I would say mostly a lot of
confidence is gone very and um yeah
maybe that's because they're their
little Papa Faker in there they don't
have the papa now with Faker back in the
starting lineup after 31 days he's back
after his wrist injury but is he at 100%
glacial prison comes in aiming is going
to be interrupted by owner absolutely
beautiful play now ker taking some
damage with the feather st's going to
save Gushi lens has to go golden and
he's not going to be able to get himself
out of it Kean is going to be the first
to go down in the fight and T1 are just
juggling the aggro gorgeously go going
to be the next victim here as T1 are
looking for match point they are looking
for no mercy and they want to head
towards the final they leave the baron
there's a black forward from Gushi the
cage is down B he avoids the feather but
it does not matter thei grabs the double
the NEX turret will be taken down at T1
will deny the reverse sleep and they'll
meet geni again tomorrow and qualify for
the World
Championship all right before we get
into faker's remarkable return just a
quick reminder to like the video
subscribe to the channel and ring the
notification Bell so you don't miss the
next great story that we're helping to
tell cheers t1s 2022 season ended in
heartbreak they lost a nailbiter of a
final to DRX in the biggest match of the
year where the inexperience of their
young roster really showed but when fans
and analysts started pointing fingers a
lot of the blame was put on the team's
veteran and star Faker many people
believe that 2022 was faker's last real
chance at a world championship and his
failure to lead his team across the
Finish Line left question marks looming
over the entire roster's future but
despite this T1 decided to stick
together ahead of the 2023 season and
once the spring split rolled around they
still looked like a top team that's
going to the end of peanut and these
Nexus turet are not long for the world
another kill comes in as Doran he goes
back to base and watches it explode
chovi goes golden on the fountain fake
is going to join him there right as the
Nexus goes down T1 two zero Revenge
maybe they'll play with their food as
well looking for a little dive onto the
fountain they're trying to bait in Faker
and they will take down the Nexus in
time bunch of good nature buddies as 16
to one is the final kill score as well
easiest game for T1 as they skated to
the victory as now de is bearing down
the wrong direction here towards T1 who
are just taking all of his stuff oh
showmaker just thrown into the blender
speaking of which Kushi now under the
turret he's going to die but so is De
and the game is now done T1 will wrap it
up two to one Faker team dominated the
spring group stage only dropping a
single match and in playoffs they kept
up that form all the way to the Grand
finals but that was where they fell
short as in front is the Zion he's going
to stand up look at this turret it just
evapor a massive Cube from Doren and it
is the man that played so well in games
one and two that's coming back here in
game three to dominate T1 owner down to
his g once again Pace he's down very
very low but now the Nexus will be in
the sights of gen they couldn't take
them down at all throughout the rest of
it and now on the blood of T1 paay has
paved the Golden Road here in Spring
2023 and when Faker and T1 attended MSI
their form continued to crumble and as
T1 falls to the lower bracket
jdg guarantees themselves the highest
finish they will be waiting in that
Grand Final it was supposed to be EDG it
was supposed to be geni it was supposed
to be T1 but here at MSI blg Stands
Strong in defiance of all expectations
they move to the final now for most
teams a top four finish at MSI would be
respectable but this is Faker we're
talking about by his and T1 standards
this result was a disappointment the
team looked shaky and some people began
questioning whether Faker was holding
back some of T's younger stars in the
summer split T1 started strong with
three wins in their first four matches
but behind the scenes Faker was
struggling after their win against bran
Faker began feeling some discomfort in
his arm he continued playing matches
through weeks three and four but things
turned from bad to worse on July 5th T1
announced that faker's condition hadn't
improved so he went to a hospital to get
it checked out fortunately they didn't
find any major issues but the Superstar
midlaner was going to have to sit on the
bench for a while in order to recover so
T1 called poby up from their Academy
team to replace Faker in the meantime
now T1 has a long history of Fielding
incredible backup midlaners who
developed in faker's Shadow some even
thought that now was the perfect time
for Faker to make way for a talented
up-and-comer like poy but without Faker
T1 looked lost clean two very one-sided
games and I got to say FZ this one was
not about poy no and fate he is going to
take Z out just as a Parting Gift
goodbye BD moving on down Hook is going
to connect there onto cuz is now carrier
taking so much damage he will be taken
out Poe as well is going to explode and
somehow it's another kill for the ban as
well his owner is running away PD finds
the flash incinerate look at how fast
he's going it's a double kill what
aiming on four kills on ban at 6 minutes
make it a triple oh goodness me it could
not have gone worse for T1 so I would
say mostly a lot of confidence is
gone
and maybe that's because they're they're
little Papa Faker in there they don't
have the papa the entire team looked
disjointed it felt like Zas and Poe were
constantly getting caught out and Kio
wasn't playing like the clutch player
everyone knew he was now it's no secret
that T1 has struggled with nerves in the
past but Faker was always there to keep
them calm when they needed it most his
veteran presence was a big part of what
helped them remain strong contenders in
the past few years 8 months prior they
were on the world's final stage but
without Faker T1 was spiraling out of
control they had lost seven of their
last eight matches and just barely
secured a spot in the playoffs and for
an orus story to T1 that simply wasn't
good enough they were a shadow of their
former s and fans saw the whole
situation as a disaster keep in mind
that this is the same fan base that sent
funeral wreaths to T's headquarters back
in 2020 and had publicly mocked their
own players for not performing well but
despite the endless distractions the
team faced outside the server they got a
massive morale boost when Faker decided
to return ahead of their week nine
matches T1 added that the decision was
made based on medical advice but some
fans worried that Faker might be rushing
back too soon nobody wanted to see him
re-aggravate his injury especially if T1
weren't contenders for playoffs but even
though the fans weren't expecting much
T1 started to pick up some wins that's
going to be the end of it flashing on
top of T and he just disappears as Faker
will pick up another media vote on his
way out we are done here 20-0 as T1 will
take down the series there's the na squ
will is going to flash to try and get
himself out as closer is kind of freeh
hitting there's an empress divide but
it's only on the clear who dives forward
snip snip everyone that is going to be
at least one of the kills but it's only
Faker that has fallen so far carrier
limping away there a big old Q Riot are
you here and Z is going to be able to
pick that one comfortably up and owner
is just going to smash back clear this
is gorgeous play from T1 as they split
the aggro beautifully the Nature's grasp
does come through counter- strike trying
to work out with the dragon rage kick is
just fantastic Kyle still manages to get
in there ERS divide on to two but now
that is not a tool that is left
available and clear we've seen this one
before yeah you might be to kill him but
you're not even able to do that this
time around as T1 the third time of
asking will claim the Nexus and make it
a 2-1 over live sandbox here today Faker
didn't look outstanding but T1 got the
job done and ended the final week of the
regular season with two wins giving them
some much needed confidence heading into
playoffs still T1 had a long way to go
if they wanted to compete with the lck's
top rosters sure they won a couple
matches against some weaker teams but
playoffs are a completely different
Beast death trying to find some Autos
but look at that Q3 and Zas will not be
silence the dust blade makes him
untargetable and Canyon is doing
everything that he can to escape but
he's not going to be able to stop this
Nexus from exploding as T1 looked
dominant in the later game and will take
down D+ the first game of this best of
Five series and it's a double once again
I think Zas might get a p for this
particular game it's looking a little
bit like a 3-1 for T1 as they take down
the inhibitor they'll take down the
Nexus turrets and they are moving on in
the playoffs once again it's a five game
series and once again they're the team
that comes out on top unless that whing
death does way more than I expect but it
does not aiming doing some damage here
to Gushi but the Nexus is the one that's
going to go down and T1 The Underdogs
from fifth place now up against first
place they take the win and stay in the
upper bracket of playoffs Faker and T1
were beginning to look like themselves
again and their win against KT put them
in the upper bracket final against
geneng G with a spot at Worlds on the
line but geneng G were T's Kryptonite
all season long and faker's team just
wasn't ready for the Church of chovi and
it looks like ji will absorb the
pressure and should be able to take down
this game number four it's a clean ace
to the side of gen and they'll push down
and bring us to silver scrapes gen D
will continue on this path though they
will take down the Nexus it looks like
it's K and owner they are so desperate
as gen G oh here comes Guma going to
take out Pace doesn't matter gen they're
going to the finals and they have booked
their ticket to Worlds once again T1 fa
the Gen in a close fought series but
they still had one last chance to
qualify for worlds and even if Faker
still wasn't fully recovered missing out
on worlds would be Unthinkable he'd
never never made it to worlds in his
home country failing to do so twice
before if he missed the big stage in
Soul again it would only add more fuel
to the fire for his haters so this time
he wasn't going to let his opportunity
Escape him I make yeah owner is going to
twist to advance forward bdd is going to
flash away sapling is down but it
shouldn't find him fers already flashed
over shifts the Sands bdd tries to slow
him down but it does not work it is
going to be the baron secured can KT
Escape is the question nature is cross
bringing kushi's going to press the old
button there's the cleanse as well it's
beautiful and be's going to be taken
down the sting also dead as kean's just
trying to keep him busy it's the double
now and Gushi is just trying to keep
them here they're celebrating on the
enemy Nexus at the end of game one look
at these extendo beams from Gushi having
a day out on the Zer here in this one
they take down the remaining turret yeah
carrier is going to suffer a death it's
his first one for the series though
we'll give it to him and T1 victorious
in game number one glacial prison comes
in aiming is going to be interrupted by
owner absolutely beautiful play now
carrier taking some damage with the
feather Storm's going to save Gushi lens
has to go golden and he's not going to
be able to get himself out of it Keane
is going to be the first to go down in
the fight and T1 are just juggling the
aggro gorgeously CO's going to be the
next victim here as T1 are looking for
match point they are looking for no
mercy and they want to head towards the
final they leave the Baron there's a
Flash Forward from Gushi the cage is
down B he avoids the feather stor but it
does not matter Gushi grabs the double
the next turret will be taken down and
T1 will deny the reverse sweep and
they'll meet geni again tomorrow and
qualify for the World Championship Faker
and T1 fended off the reverse sweep and
managed to close out the lower finals
and qualify for worlds they may have
fallen to geni in the grand finals but
after a year where some people question
whether fake still had What it Took he
silenced all of his doubters and that's
why so many people consider him the goat
after a summer filled with pain and
frustration Faker showed us that he's
still the glue that holds T1
together T1 may not coming into Worlds
as the favorites but they're certainly
contenders and after a season where
nearly everything was against them
that's already a remarkable achievement
in and of itself this year might be
faker's last real chance to lift the
Summoner Cup on home soil but with the
unkillable Demon King in the server it
seems like just about anything is
possible thanks for watching if you want
more content like this hit the sub
button and ring the notification Bell
for a unique bite-sized videos you won't
find anywhere else hit up our Twitter
Instagram Facebook and Tik
Tok